treasure hunting is a great summer
activity and you can do it with the fam
at ferguson's downtown market shop so
connie santos is here to give us a sneak
peek at their summer gyms how are you
i'm doing good thank you happy to be
here oh we're so excited to see all this
because what i love most about this all
local businesses right coming together
you guys are showcasing their art so
let's start with the hat down there yes
so the everything like you said is all
from local makers so this is from
vibesco um so
the person that's part of that his
name's tyree he designs everything i
love again we have also homemade candles
these are all handmade candles can i
smell it yeah of course you know we
picked this one because we figured it
would be a nice summer scent
oh my gosh this is amazing rising oh and
i bet who whoever made this has an
assortment yes she does her name is
ashley
ashley girl you know what you're doing
okay let's keep going let's keep going
yes so then we have different stickers
as well so these are all by local makers
they design them so we have sacred bread
um we have
black girl existing and then we also
have
let me see here we have these
earrings as well so we have these these
are roof earrings we thought these would
be great with the summer colors the
smiley face senior producers in my ear
like oh my god i want those yes we love
the different colors super cute and this
is actually seed paper so this is
something that's definitely new
um yeah it's actually i'm trying to
remember the name i apologize that's
okay yeah we just gotta go down and find
out ourselves exactly so the seed paper
it's something you can give to people
and they can plant it
paper pulp there you go yeah you write
on it as well yeah you can write
just recycle paper unique stationery
elevate your stationery okay let's keep
it going um and then here we have some
facial mist so that is definitely
handmade as well
this is actually by flower faction okay
and then we have wellness for the wild
tea so anytime any type of herbal blends
that's what we kind of have in that
option we have skin care so we have rose
face cream so this is daria soap so she
specializes in different varieties of
skincare as well that's amazing so we
only have a few more seconds left so i
want to get to the apparel over here
because this is all really dope of
course yeah so the peril this is vibes
as well
sacred bread
guy yeah and then this is depressed
monsters with the hat i love the
corduroy effects um we also have some
bags crowded mouth and lefty's lounge
and then also we have this brim hat from
major access
and then we also have savory bread as
well as this art is also here oh see
this is really cool this is really cool
you guys see that whoa yes that's so
interesting okay now tell everybody how
they can find you um yes so you can find
us on instagram at the gather house so
the gather house is where we're located
there's six micro shops so we're one of
them i love that i think this hat would
look really cute on you yes let's see it
let's see it let's see it yes connie so
cute you guys have to come down to all
such unique gifts for yourself or for
someone else yeah absolutely everybody
helps to put back into the local
community definitely that's that's the
most important part we'll be right back
in las vegas now